this is Startalk I did this after this
whole dust-up with the dress color is it
the dress color dust-up yeah yeah so but
I said let me not get let me let me know
I tried to pull back and let me not go
in with two feet
I want to dip a toe in it so here's my
toe if we're honest about shortcomings
of human physiology then optical
illusions would instead be labeled brain
failure a little bit more than an
optical illusion or a little bit less
but you can't tell me it's not a brain
failure yeah except we've reasoned it
out no the fact that it looks different
in different angles or different people
see it means the brain is not getting
the information properly interpreting it
correct the word properly the wise old
people thought that they were right in
the green and black blue and black
people thought they were right and right
those were both right it depended on the
camera boosting the thing and how bright
it was how your brain reacted and but
now you're doing our best as observers
neill scientific method starts with an
observation I this is I'm so dare you
hone I am so glad I live in an era where
we replace all of our senses with
machines well but the machines are built
by people who could touch and feel see
in here yeah and now they build a
machine that can touch see feeling here
better than they can
yes and I'm good with that yeah okay I
mean you can feel mm you can feel the
thickness of a sheet of paper between
your fingers but if you really want to
know it you get yourself with micrometer
that was 2,000 making it up we got three
seconds of an inch let the record show
you use inches in that I caught you I
caught you
Bill Nye thanks for being with me on how
to eat it is join the conversation
follow us at Star talk radio on Twitter
I'm Neil deGrasse Tyson as always I bid
you to keep looking up this is Startalk
[Music]